[Music]
in sleep swallowing news submitted by
ib+ a woman swallowed her engagement
ring in her sleep what what did she do
she where single ladies you're gonna get
Lata he's single gentlemen nothing but
DMS from guys men supporting men yeah
all right so this girl her name is Jenna
she recently got engaged and she said
that she was having this crazy intense
dream where she was on a high-speed
train [ __ ] and the tracks she's
sucking some guys yeah a high-speed
train and so her fiance was by her side
but then that's when some bad guys
appeared on the train and they were
robbing people like describe it like
James Bond oh I just picture a [ __ ]
stagecoach robbery like [ __ ] comes in
again not very far Vandana Billy the Kid
comes on yeah so then he her fiance told
her in order to protect her 2.4 carat
diamond engage ring to swallow it so
that is big I mean she could have just
stuck it up her [ __ ] or something
because it's took it up her [ __ ] her
job does it say anything about that you
can put it under your tongue like why
would you swap like eat it what she's
asleep so she didn't really know and
it's a dream yeah I just put up her butt
all your dream putting up her butt but
she could
that was really happening she's gonna go
okay my mind [ __ ] blanked out and it
immediate caught up to where we were
talking about the the Train Robbery and
I thought her and her husband was at the
was really in the Train that's so you
really meant it why did she stick it in
her [ __ ] yeah but keep it read in her
sleep
I know I know that part I just don't
know how it connected I see yeah cuz I
missed a dream part okay so yeah this is
all a dream
and so she popped off her ring and then
put in her mouth and swallowed it with a
glass of water and then she woke up and
then she realized that she didn't have a
ring on her finger
I bet you get ambien that's why no so
apparently she's had of sleepwalking
like she she's very active active sleep
so now she's like sleep eating - yeah no
any sleep walkers you guys are asleep
Walker
oh thank god brother I could get out of
his bed and walk around a video Nicki
says that I'm such a [ __ ] I've become a
deep sleeper so I'll fall asleep
downstairs in consciousness and she
comes and gets me and I have no
recollection same so I'll get up go to
bed okay so that's kind of like assisted
sleepwalking I guess but I think real
sleep are you sleepwalking is when you
just get up go downstairs you [ __ ] do
[ __ ] you make eggs
yeah that's dangerous you throw the
purse in the fridge I would have no if I
sleepwalk or knock some sleep in well
didn't wake up in the same place you
know things are moved around like we
talked about someone before where she
had to lock up her food because she was
sleep eating shoes Danny oh my god they
had to lock up their keys because they
were trying to go in the car and well my
when my dad got remarried he made it
Slater had to to like little girls and
one of them was like 7 years old
remember my dad like warning me like hey
just so you know like um her name was
Rachel he's like chichi like sleepwalks
um okay so I spent the night over my dad
and I just remember like because I slept
in the living room I remember like just
this little girl like by the wall and
that she was like talking to the door
and then I was like that's I don't know
I just kind of went back to bed
dude I was like let's know your number
wake them up like you can [ __ ] it up she
likes to wear 18th century nightgown so
just so you know it's it's a terrible
combination yeah what happens to people
when you wake them up during
sleepwalking cuz I always like I know
that that's the stuff you're not
supposed to like do it but I just want
to do it creepy wake up [ __ ] I also
like how people treat sleepwalkers like
they're jacked into the matrix and you
can't you can't [ __ ] die there yeah
like what's with that Oh 30% of children
between the ages of 5 and 12 experienced
at least one sleepwalking episode Wow oh
my brother he was really young but he
doesn't do it anymore
I don't know I don't live with them but
it's a myth that it's dangerous to wake
up a sleepwalker oh it's a myth
so you just knock him out I'd slap him I
knew it PAH wake up [ __ ] they
can't feel it if I slap them when
there's no me bucket of cold water yeah
but see we all believed that I someone
told us yes some [ __ ] well I thought
they would short-circuit and their
[ __ ] comes like have a seizure so
they're saying that if you're like
vigorously shaking them it might confuse
or just stress them temporarily
okay so slap them and then when they're
disoriented they might strike out anyone
oh that's true so you kind of put
yourself in danger a little bit yeah
someone bigger it just starts [ __ ]
joke a cup on the back there no so
they're saying instead it's just just to
simply guide them back to bed yeah
dude you'll be [ __ ] crazy what if
like they are in a different dimension
and then they're talking to spirits and
[ __ ] while they're sleepwalking dreams
yeah so what if they're like I don't
want it I don't want to hurt them and in
like like [ __ ] Eric's sleeping I
don't want to hurt him he's nice [ __ ]
that I'm definitely kicking someone in
the face
to say that she'd like out loud he said
that is she's like no but I don't want
to hurt oh dude already the kitchen grab
a knife [ __ ] dense to run in families
why would I want to stab him right now I
don't even care if you guys wanna make
fun of me cuz I had sleep paralysis the
other night it was [ __ ] nuts
did you see ghosts so I had a dream that
or whatever I was yeah I had a dream
that I was floating around my why did
you bring it up like that who's gonna
make fun of you know they can go ahead
make for me I think it's just totally
fine and legitimate no I was floating
around my I was floating around our
house right and I'm floating downstairs
like in my office area the astral
projection [ __ ] yeah floating this way
or like this way or like this one
existed like like this receive the
little iron man and yeah all right rue
true
I'm just character is that so yeah I'm
floating around and then all of a sudden
I get like a wave of goosebumps over me
like 80 times like any times not are you
counting well it's like that many times
but you have to peel off sink the
crannies of the goosebumps yeah it
constantly hits me over and over and
over and over and over and then I and
then I'm frozen I can't can't really
move and I look out my bathroom window
and there's a black dog sitting there
and he starts growling at me and then
I'm like oh [ __ ] I got to get back into
my body this is the dream dog it's evil
dog he's like growling at me
and he starts barking at me and he's
like I locked with me and then I can't
[ __ ] move at all and then I'm like
yelling trying to get to try to get back
into my body or whatever cuz that's how
it feels in the dream and then Nicky
heard me while I was asleep like she
heard you in your dream
you heard me like like in real life like
going this happens to me and then she so
she will she said in real life she heard
him she heard me in real life yeah oh
and then she wakes me up she wakes me up
and then I am me I'm a meeting like oh
thank you thank you thank you so much
cuz she you're actually screaming a real
life like ah like yeah like my body was
like bad a baby well you it would have
been so much Dober if she had that
connection and she's sleeping - and she
was in the [ __ ] spiritual Steve needs
me wake up honey
since our D sit down I got ya
he was she was gonna be protecting him
from the dog in that other dimension
no no cuz Nikki be scared in the dream
she'll be ok alright that's what they're
like a real nice show she'll she'll be
like oh I need [ __ ] I need help Steve
yes she knows to do that in real life
yeah that helped me a lot but that's a
trip it's scary in the moment you're
like oh [ __ ] this feels very real yeah I
felt like stranger things ass [ __ ] dude
you were in the [ __ ] nether regions I
was in the nether world brother
underneath this look at my house oh I
[ __ ] know I burned that condo and I
run away yep
I've never had probably arson no I've
had one where it was like I I don't know
what I was watching where I was watching
something about like demons and and
getting questioning the idea of like is
there such things as demons and whatnot
and I just knocked out on the couch and
I removed the last thing I saw was like
Michael my curtains in my living room
that I have these uh leave I think these
dark grey curtains remember I fell
asleep and I remember like saying in my
dream like that's not really you're not
real like this [ __ ] isn't real and I
don't know we're like an imprint of like
a demon type thing came from my curtains
and it was like choking me and I was
just like you couldn't breathe anything
I couldn't breathe nothing and then when
I woke up I realized that I fell asleep
like this oh really choking and like my
real so so it's crazy how that was my
dream yeah that it was probably worse
Felicity to the audio something dude I
don't know what I was watching but I
just remember questioning it going to
sleep seeing that I'm like it's real you
know like buck alright so back to this
woman here she ended up waking up her
fiancee and said
I swallowed my joy my ring and then so
they end up googling if adults often
swallow rings but usually kids do it so
why are they googling that at Google how
the [ __ ] do I get it back yeah yeah so
they were they end up going to Urgent
Care and that's when the doctors decided
against letting the ring pass naturally
through her system and so don't let it
out instead they refer to to a
gastroenterologist row enter ologist and
that's when they performed an upper end
endoscopy and then what's that endoscopy
is when they they put a camera down your
throat it's like a surgery so then they
[ __ ] grab the ring and then they pull
it back out grab it and take it out yeah
yeah I bet the [ __ ] fiance was like I
don't give a [ __ ] cut that [ __ ] open to
dreams ward
dude turn upside down shake the [ __ ]
the fiancee you got a chocolate lab I
like Labradors x-ray whoa
that's gonna stop me what's what is this
stuff her rib she's dying is that gas I
don't know this is like during the
endoscope oh damn
that's what it looks like I found it
yeah they found an it's like they got a
camera and that little claw you know
dollar machines with this stuff bear
yeah yeah you know the quarter but the
doctor like give me another quarter and
like we shouldn't have charged for this
if only it was 25 cents up and uh sure
yeah I used to clean those cameras it's
pretty weird seeing them back buddy
little tiny huh no it's like a snake
it's like a snake there's a lens below
yeah there's a claw at the end they just
wanted to get my kidney stone now but
they had to go in through my dick oh
thanks a lot
there's a claw at the end I think so
there's something at the end what
they're able to grab it Oh chef ro I
don't remember it's been so long
somewhere between these two spices
yeah that's pretty thick maybe this one
I think it's 2000 when it goes down yeah
that's pretty thick stuff about though
is how did they get that thing that's
they had to pull it through my dick huh
pull it back up nothing well did I do
here might they went through dick anyone
up here ah oh you think they pull it out
of my mouth a magic trick irfan was out
to the large and little thing like a
whistle yeah yeah image of this let's
play we're in town they're just
[Music]
[Music]